hello and welcome to google developers
live my name is Arun Nagarajan and I'm
with the google apps developer relations
team today we have a very special guest
on the show we have a great partner
Avery and they're going to be talking
about the the great Google Docs and
Google sheets add-ons that they've been
working on and before we dive into all
the demos and interesting conversation I
want have Brad introduce himself hello
my name is brad nelson from Avery
products corporation I'm very glad to be
here with air and seeing you again after
Google i/o the business I'm in is being
able to have people by our various
products from staples or whatever
distributor might have it take the
Stockholm and load it in your printer
use one of our applications to design a
customized label or card or perhaps a
business card or a greeting card and
then you print it right on your own
printer at home we have materials suited
for inkjet and for laser so got you
covered it has the consumer that's great
why don't we actually do a very quick
demo of the the product I don't you glad
to do that all right say quick look yep
so this was developed with Google Apps
Script and we've been working on it on
and off for a few months I wouldn't say
we've been spending full time on it but
it's been really easy to do I really
like the technology my background is
quite a bit of client-server Java flash
HTML and so I'm very familiar with the
model and it was quite simple and easy
to put this application together right
so let's dive into it let's do it so
this is called Avery design and print
app for Google Drive and on our first
screen this is a web-based release we
could either pick between a Google
spreadsheet or Google contacts so let's
say that I pick spreadsheet then I hit
the next button very simple interface
it shows a list of all the spreadsheets
that I have in my own google drive and
so i'll just pick one of these called
address list i have to press a button
here so that i can run apps script that
will actually parse that spreadsheet and
convert it into a csv stream and once
I've done that there will be a little
spinner it finishes and if I hit the
merge button I'll actually be taking
that data into our website for emerged
but what I'd rather do is show that
second step with contacts so we'll just
back up here and we'll do the same
process will start with contacts instead
of spreadsheets go to next and I have
the option of picking either home or
work addresses because we're going to
make mailing labels from contacts and I
could actually after picking one say
well what if there isn't a home address
there's only a work address so we have
this little checkbox there that says use
either one so it'll prefer home if it's
not there to look for a work address
again I have to go grab the contacts and
format that into a CSV format and now
I'm ready to merge at this point we're
going to enter the design and print
online application and while that loads
we have a large range of products on the
left side of the screen here business
cards labels I'm going to go with a
label of 5160 is very common mailing
label
and then it's going to show of series of
designs these are called pre-designed
templates so we'll just pick any one of
those and after it loads the template
you see the merge data that's come out
of contacts so we show a spreadsheet
format here and if you want to not
include all the rows of contacts you can
simply disable the ones you don't want
to merge and then you can go on at this
step we are allowing you to do a
drag-and-drop interface so that you can
specify where you want the fields from
that contact list to show up and
typically just be name address and i can
drag over country and so these fields
are filled in and the merge will be
completed and i will go to the design
canvas and you can see the actual data
so this is one of the contacts in my
contact list here's a few more so each
one of these labels here has been merged
from google contacts so that's really
nice app script and to complete the demo
we would go into preview and printing so
you can see what the sheet of avery
labels would look like this is a
shipping label format but this is a 30
up we call it mailing label and i'm
going to go ahead and show that we
create a PDF file which we can open and
at this point we could print it oh well
thank you very much for sharing that
with us and giving your insights on app
script and i hope you find that really
useful and more interesting more
importantly i hope you go check out the
add-on and install it and try it out i
think it's it's going to be really
useful especially around the holidays
especially around other times we need to
send out a lot of either greeting cards
or mailing labels I know I've use the
product so that's great well we're
looking forward to doing and add
on your store next an app for the store
that you suggested to us for
spreadsheets so that'll be our next
evolution great thank you very much